why didn't somebody  because he's literally the Auntie woke  like he's the Auntie of everything that  they're promoting so I don't even think  it has anything to do with his um  so-called views I don't really think  that mistake but I think it has  everything to do with the fact that he's  pulling people out of the Matrix so he's  waking people up he's saying nobody's  coming to save you forget that nine to  five you need to save yourself you don't  need antidepressants let me teach you  how to fight depression by yourself what  does that do because the pharmaceutical  companies out of work right and so it's  because he's a literally empowering men  to save themselves and I think that men  are the Forefront of society like if you  have weak men Society funnels if you  have strong women it does  the men that matter so if you have  strong men then Society can flourish in  every different way